[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça t'a fait de rencontrer
le Père Noël
ça m'a fait drôle
c'est comme quand comme si vous aviez un
éclair au dessus de vous qui vous
frappez c'était
et
j'étais aussi très content
et timide un peu
ça va
cette question pour moi n'a jamais été
une question anodine
quand en face de moi j'entends
une hésitation ou du une réponse
négative je ne continue pas mon chômage
et je m'intéresse à la personne voilà
certainement une des raisons pour
laquelle ma vie a croisé un jour celle
d'Edgar
très tôt dans ma vie j'ai voulu sortir
effectivement de mon cadre familial de
mon cadre professionnel pour faire
d'autres choses et j'avais envie de me
donner à une cause de faire des choses
mais je ne savais pas quoi je ne savais
pas ce que j'allais faire je ne savais
pas pour quelle cause j'allais
me donner
et en fait dans la vie je crois que on
ne choisit pas la cause c'est la chose
qui c'est la la cause qui vous choisit
pour moi le choix s'est fait à travers
la maladie de Raphaël m'en neveu qui a
l'âge de 12 ans a été atteint par une
tumeur cérébrale quand j'ai su ça je me
suis mis au service de sa famille
et je l'ai décidé d'essayer d'amener des
moments de bonheur à Raphaël parce que
on sait très bien que le mental le moral
sont des ingrédients
extraordinaires dans la lutte contre la
maladie pour les enfants et les adultes
et donc j'ai organisé des merveilleux
moments pour Raphaël il était fan de
foot j'avais incarné d'adresses
intéressantes je l'ai fait inviter au
Paris Saint-Germain où il a rencontré
son idole de l'époque en aldinho je lui
ai obtenu aussi des des maillots
dédicacés
et à chaque fois je constatais
les normes est fait sur son moral
peut-être l'équivalent de plusieurs
chimiothérapies
malheureusement Rafael nous a quitté
j'étais anéanti mais une chose était
sûre j'avais trouvé ma cause et j'avais
envie d'accompagner le combat des
enfants malades dans leur parcours
donc j'ai créé quelques années après
l'association en Raphaël qui organise
les rêves enfin qui réalise les rêves
d'enfants gravement malade et organise
des activités pour eux
en liaisant directe avec un hôpital
parce que j'ai voulu que cette
association elle travaille au service
des soignants c'est eux qui choisissent
les enfants qui valident les rêves et
donc on est juste des gens qui sont le
prolongement de la médecine
vous parlez de ce soir ce soir de ce
sujet c'est contradictoires parce que
quand vous décidez dans votre vie
d'aller vers de l'humanitaire du
solidaire
c'est une démarche de discrétion et
d'humilité l'exercice que je fais ce
soir et bien sûr tout à fait le
contraire
mais j'ai rapidement dû être visible et
du partager le besoin de partager cette
envie de monter ses projets parce qu'il
a fallu que je fédère autour de moi des
des énergies pour m'accompagner je
pouvais pas le faire seul et j'avais
besoin de mes scènes aussi de façon à
financer mes projets
donc voilà j'étais au carré je voulais
faire des choses
mais comment faire comment redonner le
sourire à des enfants qui n'ont plus
envie de sourire comment donner aux
familles l'envie de faire des projets
alors qu'elles ne se projette plus en
fait comment donner envie à une équipe
de gagner alors qu'elle n'a même plus
envie de jouer
et pour faire tout ça vous n'êtes que
bénévole ça veut dire que vous n'avez
pas eu de formation
vous n'avez pas de coach comme j'en ai
eu un pour cette soirée
mais vous n'êtes pas là par hasard vous
avez de l'empathie vous avez de l'amour
à donner et vous avez une énorme envie
d'emmener ses enfants sur le chemin de
la guérison et de les accompagner
mais comment faire quoi faire et là
l'idée que j'ai eu c'est de dire je vais
les sortir eux aussi du cadre je vais
les sortir du carcan de la maladie du
carcan des traitements et je vais les
emmener vers le rêve éveillé de se dire
plus rien n'est impossible on va croire
en deux mains et on va leur organiser
des choses exceptionnelles
auxquelles il n'avait jamais songé je
leur fais réaliser des choses terribles
et ça provoque aussi chez eux des
réactions assez extraordinaires
c'est l'histoire d'Elora et l'orage je
l'ai connu en 2016
et Laura en 2016 et atteinte d'une
leucémie extrêmement agressive et à
l'Arve c'est de rencontrer la chanteuse
Louane
donc bien sûr en organise ce rêve pour
l'emmener au spectacle malheureusement
la veille du spectacle le vendredi
le médecin m'appelle et il dit écoute on
pourra pas le faire parce que les
résultats sanguins ne sont pas
suffisamment bons et on prendrait un
trop gros risques en la laissant aller
dans un concert où il y a beaucoup de
monde
mais le médecin est tenace il revient le
samedi matin il refait une prise de sang
et en jouant il m'appelle et il me dit
la prise de sang est meilleure je te
donne l'autorisation
petit miracle assez extraordinaire comme
je suis aussi tenace que le médecin
jarcelle la production de Louane qui est
un peu réticente à une rencontre et ils
acceptent la rencontre donc le soir même
le cancer est magnifique la rencontre
est magnifique mais avec une émotion
toute particulière de la maman
qui me dit après le cancer en fait j'ai
appris ce matin que ma fille bien sûr
pouvait sortir pour venir ici mais en
même temps on m'a appris qu'elle est en
soi palliatif
imaginez la détresse de cette maman ce
soir là
et Laura a continué à se battre avec un
courage énorme quand la maladie et
quelques semaines après l'hôpital Necker
propose à sa famille de mettre loin dans
un protocole
de façon à expérimenter un nouveau
traitement la famille accepte bien sûr
et il aura par trois ans à Paris trois
ans compliqué avec des moments
extrêmement difficiles mais il aura elle
a un courage hors normes
trois ans plus tard les chercheurs de
l'hôpital Necker font une conférence de
presse avec Elora à leur côté
et il déclare qu'elle aura est la
première enfant dans le monde
à être guéri
de cette leucémie
moment extraordinaire que je ne sais pas
vous expliquer je sais pas ce qu'il y a
ce qui a fait que les revenus d'un
chemin compliqué quel chemin des soins
palliatifs
mais j'ai la faiblesse de penser qu'à
samedi matin lors d'une prise de sang en
a permis à Elora d'exprimer son
extraordinaire potentiel de lutte son
extraordinaire résilience
beaucoup de belles histoires en
jalonnais les 10 ans de cette
association mais malheureusement elle ne
termine pas tout aussi bien
et on s'y était préparé puisque de toute
façon quand vous travaillez avec des
enfants quand c'est vous savez que c'est
une issue qui peut arriver parce que
malheureusement les médecins ne gagnent
pas toujours le combat et là on s'est
dit ces enfants là on va leur faire
vivre des choses exceptionnelles on va
me rendre leur vie extraordinaire de
façon à remplacer la durée par
l'intensité après tout la vie sur
l'échelle humaine c'est pas grand chose
dans quelques années plus ou moins c'est
pas l'essentiel c'est surtout la façon
dont on va les vivre
et donc on a décidé de provoquer des
moments extraordinaires pour remplacer
la durée par l'intensité
c'est l'histoire de Yusuf
Youssouf a 14 ans il a un rêve c'est
devenir militaire par contre je souffle
et en soi palliatifs donc tout le monde
sait qui ne sera jamais militaire donc
notre idée c'est de lui permettre de
rêver pendant une journée et de le faire
recevoir dans une caserne
journée magnifique
yusuf a vécu sa vie en accéléré sur une
journée
comment ne pas vous parler de son
bonheur tout au long de cette journée
pas une douleur pas une gêne
comment ne pas vous parler de la fierté
de son papa
voyant son fils monté dans les engins et
même en uniforme au garde-à-vous sur un
char d'assaut en train de
comment ne pas vous parler aussi de
l'émotion extraordinaire de tout un
régiment qui avait accueilli en Sensa ce
jour-là un petit soldat d'une journée
ces moments bien sûr sans les moments
les plus difficiles qu'on est à vivre
mais ça fait partie de notre engagement
et je dirais même c'est nos lettres de
noblesse parce que plus le combat est
difficile plus la victoire est belle
donc c'est devenu une vraie passion
aussi de permettre ce type de moment en
impact les enfants et les familles n'ont
pas avec des bons moments mais avec des
moments extraordinaires exceptionnel
c'est l'histoire d'Alix mon copain Alix
quand je le rencontre
il est dans le service il est malade
mais il vient d'un milieu social
extrêmement défavorisé et c'est
compliqué parce que la maladie c'est dur
la misère sociale c'est dure mais
l'addition des deux c'est quand même
assez intolérable
donc j'ai envie de faire des choses pour
Alix et je l'emmène à jour au Stade de
France voir l'équipe de France de rugby
rencontrer les joueurs après le match
et le soir Alix me dit Denis
je sais très bien que si j'avais pas été
malade j'aurais jamais eu les moyens
dans ma vie de venir un jour au Stade de
France
Alix me dit en fait que la maladie est
une chance dans sa vie mais c'est
extraordinaire
donc comme je vois qu'il a une passion
alors qui s'intéressait pas à grand
chose il avait pas de copain parce que
les problèmes physiques un retard mental
donc je dis ben on va l'emmener voir
d'autres majorité je l'emmène plusieurs
fois à Clermont-Ferrand où il est même
accueilli par Morgan Parra qui est par
notre association et avec bienveillance
par tous les joueurs
et Alix vit des choses extraordinaires
il devient passionné de rugby et
passionné d'ASM et tous les samedis il a
un but c'est suivre les résultats de
cette équipe et m'envoyer des textos
pour faire des commentaires
Ali Alips adorait aussi aller à Dinard
où on va chaque année avec des enfants
pour aller faire du catamaran et
découvrir la Bretagne où on a accueilli
d'une façon extrêmement bienveillante
un jour Alix m'appelle il me dit Denis
ce matin j'ai fait j'ai fait des tests
et ils sont pas bons en ma détecté à
troisième cancer cancer à la testicule
extrêmement agressif
j'étais anéanti
mais Alix il était pas triste je
comprenais pas pourquoi il avait juste
envie de me poser une seule question
Denis si j'ai un nouveau concert ça veut
dire que je suis à nouveau prioritaire
pour aller à Dinard chouette
l'histoire d'Alix c'est malheureusement
arrêtée quelques semaines plus tard
et il est parti revêtu du maillot de
l'équipe de France de rugby
et autour de son cercueil il y avait que
des roses jaunes et bleu couleur du club
de Clermont-Ferrand volonté de sa maman
cela montre à quel point on a pu
impacter la vie d'Alix la vie de sa
famille et de tous les soignants qui
étaient bienveillants autour
nous vivons des moments extraordinaires
mais j'avais envie quand même
de poser la question au professeur
chastagnier de savoir quelle est
l'utilité réelle de tout ça
donc j'ai demandé au professeur
chastagnier professeur
pouvez-vous me dire quelle est l'impact
réel de nos actions sur
les enfants les familles et les
soignants lorsque les enfants et les
parents arrivent dans notre service du
jour au lendemain alors évidemment
c'était pas attendu c'est le ciel qui
qui sont dans une bulle d'angoisse
de soins de malheur et l'envisage pas du
tout l'avenir de façon optimiste alors
évidemment quelle est la façon de les
démarches finaliser c'est ces
associations notamment l'association
Raphaël qui permet de faire obtenir aux
enfants des rêves qui n'avaient même pas
imaginé au départ et surtout ça casse ça
fait une véritable rupture une bascule
par rapport à tout ce malheur
environnant dans l'hospitalisation et le
retentissement qu'on voit c'est des
enfants qui acceptent mieux le
traitement des parents qui sont plus
détendus et puis un personnel soignant
qui comme les parents trouvent des
enfants qui vont faire des choses vont
avoir des opinions des objectifs qui
n'étaient pas ceux d'avant il y a une
véritable bascule vers un optimisme qui
n'existait pas et ça donne vraiment de
l'espoir des parents que leur enfant
n'est pas condamné à la fois en termes
de survie mais aussi en termes de
séquelles et que tout peut aller très
bien dans un contexte comme c'est offert
par l'association Raphaël
merci aux professeur chastagnier
mais merci de ces mots c'est un homme
que j'admire bien sûr et merci de ces
mots qui donnent un véritable sens à ma
démarche
j'ai décidé d'accompagner le combat des
enfants malades
c'est devenu quelque chose de
fondamental dans ma vie ça a donné plus
qu'un sens à ma vie je pense que ça a
donné le sens de ma vie
je pense que nous avons tous besoin de
mettre du sens dans nos vies
je vous souhaite de trouver votre chemin
en donnant du sens en allant vers les
autres
peut-être que demain matin vous penserez
à moi
on vous demandant jusqu'où vous êtes
prêts à aller dans l'histoire de la
personne qui est en face de vous si vous
osez lui poser la question qui ne sera
plus pour vous anodine bonjour Comment
ça va aujourd'hui merci
[Applaudissements]